[Music]
ding-ding welcome back everybody to Gen
Julian podcast this episode is brought
to you by me underneath it you guys know
that many undies makes the world's most
comfortable not underwear but also
lounge pants panties you guys know about
their underwear
okay they're lounge pants are made from
the same micro model fabric as their me
undies just three times softer than
cotton amazing honestly I love sleeping
in them you should check it out
100 100 % satisfaction guarantee right
now get your 15% off your first order
free shipping and a hundred percent
satisfaction guys so if you don't like
it for whatever you need your money back
me undies that's meu n di es comm slash
annejulien also guys this skim the way
to educate yourself every day so you
don't have to wade through the nonsense
all over the internet that skim is a
newsletter that comes to your email
inbox is completely free with the top
news stories going on in the world right
now go to the skim that's th e s ki mm
that's two M's calm / - no Julian and
subscribe it's completely free also when
you subscribe you're gonna be entering
yourself to win a $250 Visa gift card
also guys if you want to shop for
clothes thread up is the way to do it
they have second-hand clothes clothing
options from some of the top brands with
up to 90% off retail price solid
condition wearable and really affordable
go to thre dup comm slash Jenna Julian
that's thredUP comm / Jenna Julian for
an extra 30% off your already discounted
order BAM the skin just made me realize
that like I was watching an episode of
Dallas Cowboys Cheerleaders and you know
how they have those like fake media
training oh like describe that to me
yeah so Dallas Cowboys Cheerleaders
making the team is one of my favorite
shows it's brutal they're brutal to
those girls but so they're they're the
cheerleaders for the Dallas Cowboys and
the whole season is just about who makes
the team in blah blah blah and one of
the exercises that they put them through
is they go through this like media
training where they have to you know be
in front of a camera and answer some
questions that an interviewer asked them
and they set them up with like a fake
and it's not even real it's very alive
it's going nowhere yeah and they give
them these like lay up questions like
how's training camp been for you and you
know what do you think about football in
general and this one girl who's like
doing really well in training camp a
rookie the woman was like you know what
do you think about the me to movement
and like as visible women as Dallas
Cowboys Cheerleaders do you think it's a
cheerleaders place to be involved or
speak up or anything about that she goes
I don't know what that is oh and she got
cut for that and Finn glass when she
went into the office the coach she was
like you know I really she's like where
you're getting your news and she goes
Instagram and you know what could have
really helped her out because she was
like I wish what should i do should i
listen to podcast for news like what
should i do she should have just gotten
this she should just kind of see if that
was that that was the best sponsor intro
that's ever been done on the show and
you did it thank you
so if you're considering trying out for
the Dallas Cowboys Cheerleaders don't
even think about getting that uni on
until you sign up for the skin okay
that's the only really literally only
reason I agree with Finglas cutting
someone on that show the rest of them
were nonsense oh boy yeah I mean she
literally just was like I'm speechless
and she didn't know what to do you know
about anything that's going on and she's
like I guess I don't know and and she
was just like I have no words so don't
get your news from Instagram or else
you're gonna be made a fool of in the
Dallas Cowboys chair how can you get
news from Instagram I don't I don't
think that's really a thing I mean
that's a skill in and of itself where
did you find the news part of Instagram
she have the beta for like the next
Instagram or something I don't know
she's a young girl like I understand why
if you're the head of that organization
you can't in good faith hire a young
woman that hasn't heard of that and then
risk the chance that she goes out there
and says that publicly you know what I
mean yeah it reflects really badly on
their organization yeah
but still she got cut just but not no
one oh she literally just needed to sign
up for the skim and she would have been
on the football field right now living
her dreams it's too bad mm-hmm but I you
know if I'm hiring I and I asked someone
with the Miche movement is and they say
I don't know I haven't seen that news on
Instagram I'm gonna say maybe check your
news sources next time we get to skim
but the weird thing is I would be hiring
for the skim I work for the skim they
were interviewing to work for the skim
in that scenario so Julian that's my
dream job briefly what are your thoughts
on the Conor could be play don't work
for the skin okay you can all right
reach high and jump even higher that's
what they say have the skin that's what
we say at the skin I work there no job
so are you quitting like the podcast and
like the twitch stream no it's my side
work okay I just got promoted to what
for manager Wow the skin has a lot of
force I'm in jolbon watch the skin drops
this as a sponsor now because you
because I claimed it was a joke hire me
please I don't actually work for you
hire me I'm looking for some side work
okay so briefly our thoughts on the
could be Connor yeah just because we
didn't want to do a whole podcast about
it I know some of you guys are really
over that stuff which is her if you
didn't know there was a big you have see
if her this weekend Conor McGregor
fought khabib nurmagomedov and it was
weird it was weird it was a good fight
and then there was sort of like a
miniature brawl right after the fight
which just like kind of blows as like an
MMA fan it's like you never want to see
that because immediately everyone's
reactions is like damn this sport is
vicious and stupid you know I don't know
my thoughts on the fight was khabib did
exactly what he needed you to be the guy
like Connor and there's there's people
who are like wow could be was a boring
fighter but I by the way it's not going
to take long we have something else
planned for today just look at the title
for those who have watched kabhi which
weirdly a lot of people didn't know
about could be you know outside of the
MMA fan world but like he's been tearing
it up for years he's under had 26 wins
going into that fight yeah he's an
absolute animal but he doesn't win
fights by laying and praying that's like
a term they used for wrestlers who just
like take you down and hold you down and
win the fight there was a clear strategy
that was his strategy yes and that is
definitely one of the strengths he's
like a bear he can hold you down he
holds the record for most takedowns in a
single was it five round fight or three
round fight for 21 takedowns like that's
so stir his goal is to get you on the
ground and especially in Connors big
rounds one and two where he will knock
you out
khabib already had him on the ground and
it's which was via a strike to the face
yeah and then he got him down after that
all good points Connor has never
finished someone outside of the second
round so he neutralized Connor put him
on his back for the first two rounds
right which we know that that's when the
crowd boos and everyone doesn't like it
but he literally had his legs wrapped up
like it was a strategy and he executed
it incredibly well as boring as it might
have looked that is so incredibly hard
to do against a guy like Connor who's
athletic like Connor that level grapple
high it looks boring I get it but my
point was khabib isn't that fighter like
he destroys people he knocks them out he
submits them he like gets them to the
ground has some of the most terrifying
ground-and-pound that that anyone has
ever dealt with so yes like it was maybe
for most people like I want to see them
stand up and punch you know they did for
a little bit
could be hats off like amazing amazing
fight sport you don't get to see people
stand up and strike each other unless
it's two strikers fighting against each
other this to watch mixed martial arts
go watch more time if you don't want to
see grappling stop booing when they're
on the ground and he's submitting him
it's a concept understand they want
because they love Connors attitude and
his [ __ ] judge and they want to see
him get in there and judge it up then
then watch Connor fight [ __ ] one of
the Diaz's again yeah they want to see a
street fight with some bad attitudes but
that doesn't always happen because
unfortunately you have to fight the
other athletes some of which are
grapplers mixed martial arts Kermit's
licking the floor in the closet just
letting everybody know
after the fighting was just kind of like
gross basically khabib team well khabib
jumped the fence and went for Dylan
Danis who's a cornermen and a grappler
himself of Conor McGregor's Dylan had
been talking a lot of shits it can be
even his team so khabib jumped over the
fence and just like saw red and just
attacked him and then meanwhile Cubs
team jumped the fence into the cage and
sort of attacked Connor when he was like
kind of defenseless which was shitty the
whole thing was shitty I don't even
think there's really a need to get into
it like there was a lot of shitty things
leading up to this fight Connor isn't
blameless in this whole situation you
know he's the whole bus incident where
he broke the window with a bus with a
dolly and hurt some people and said the
things he said regardless go out
religion our religious father yeah and
like a lot of you know a lot of people
don't understand you know about politics
yeah about politics for like you're not
you don't understand what it's like to
be from a place that you're not from
like khabib said he said where I'm from
we don't take that ever lightly ever
like if someone insults my family my
religion my country all bets are off
this is him that's not promoting the
fight yeah yeah and to Connor he's he's
doing what he does best which is a you
know way has chalked all of these things
up to saying bad things and
trash-talking and be running a fight
which again like two wrongs don't make a
right is like the biggest takeaway from
all this like Connor did wrong could be
bit wrong none of it's right like it's
just you know well so I have a couple
questions for you yeah and I don't think
that you had the answers because I don't
think anyone has the answers but what we
talked about last night
with Mark and everything so they use the
bus footage where Conor McGregor threw
the dolly into the bus which resulted in
michael Chiesa getting her and he
privately sued Connor for that because
he missed the fight for that he's
currently in the middle yeah
and the kebee was on that bus right
mm-hmm
yeah or can be beating me right yeah
somebody and that was ugly and nasty and
they use that footage to promote the
fight do you think that Dana has any
sort of level of responsibility for
profiting off of and encouraging that
type of behavior and then suddenly when
it boils down to the safety of everyone
inside that arena when could be decides
to jump the fence and incite a brawl
basically do you think that any of that
is Dana's responsibility yes I do 100%
and I think he'll never admit to it
because he's Dana and it's like in this
situation he's he's kind of removing
himself from the situation he's like
okay let's see what the Commission says
like let's let the penalties happen
right but in reality if you don't use
the bus footage in a promotion in a
promotional video leading to a fight
then what that does is it takes away
that situation as something that's even
remotely okay in the fighters eyes or
the team's eyes because there were
nothing consequences for no consequences
well the that we know of I mean
obviously you probably had to deal with
some legal situations and maybe somebody
it's not like you got suspended there
was no UFC consequences for correct
that's right so the fact that the UFC
didn't didn't penalize Connor for
throwing a dollar through a bus window
and hurting people and basically causing
it's battery right it's aggravated
assault and battery to an extent you're
including that situation to promote a
fight you're by doing that you're saying
okay well this is you're being complicit
you're being complicit and you're also
normalizing that sort of thing so then
when can be jumped the fence he's like
this is gonna be used in the next promo
video I don't care
well cuz Dana said I would use it again
because it's quote part of the story
yeah and Dana is a there's so much of
what he does is just brilliant and I
respect the hell out of him but at the
same time I know that sometimes when
when he's you know he's you know he's
being held to the fire he's not he's
never gonna give it up he's never gonna
just be like yeah I [ __ ] up right you
know especially in a situation like this
where it's like it's so easy to put the
blame on all the other you know parties
that also deserve blame but I believe
that if you don't use that footage in a
promotional fight it sets a whole
different tone going into this fight
that's not to say that if they didn't
use the footage and khabib did what he
did anyway like it could have happened
anyway because of what Connor had done
and said and dallisa 'td out of his team
so I think he was just kind of ugly all
around I think after the bus incident
Dana was like this is terrible I'm
shocked and then he goes and uses it in
the pair
video and you're like okay well what is
it you know like are you happy are you
happy behind closed doors that this
happen because it's great for promo or
you actually piss and shocked I don't
know I don't you know I don't like
seeing a UFC champion do act that sort
of way I think it's kind of foolish it
reminds me of like the early days of the
UFC when it was just like a [ __ ] show so
I don't know my next question for you is
when we were sitting there watching
could be you've jumped the fence and
start literally a brawl outside of the
Octagon my first reaction was like come
on be like you're ruining it come on
[ __ ] stop it but also I thought that
he was gonna be arrested on the spot
because he went out there he punched
somebody like there's not gonna be any
belt there's not gonna like you got to
sold outside of they just broke the law
and I understand like Connor had done
that to Jose Aldo and he sort of got up
in his face
but he never liked threw punches or
kicks in the audience right charged like
it's been done before that someone's
jumped on the Octagon and sort of got
people riled up yeah but has it happened
in the UFC that someone has jumped out
and just brawl because I've seen people
jump into the Octagon including Conor
but that wasn't UFC was that no these
have been other yeah other events have
had this like horrible things happen
right there's like strike force had it
like Bellator has had we're just right
nonsense happens do you think because I
I genuinely thought he was leaving in
handcuffs like you can't do that yeah
and like the way that that could have
escalated is just really terrifying do
you think that there should be
consequences for what khabib did and
obviously it's up to the Nevada Athletic
Commission or whatever to decide what
happens to his title but what do you
think should happen to well there's like
what I mean like in the law enforcement
arena because if when you come to that
do you think that they're separate yeah
yes yeah they are definitely are
separate so what happens I think so the
khabib team got arrested like three of
them got arrested right and then Conor
didn't want to press charges so they got
let go right but also like I can't I
can't say that that's a bad thing
because Conor's in no position to press
charter and say what you will about
Conor he's a big talker he's a big
personality but he always loses with
class he's never the guy who's gonna
he's never gonna you know lose a fight
and then cause
just [ __ ] right on the spot yeah he's
gonna internalize it and use it for the
next rematch or whatever but like he
he's a classy fighter yeah when he loses
and he was classy he sat there he's also
just a little he's a little Irish Street
boy like somebody sucker-punched me and
I got ganged up on like I'm not gonna
press charges it's not in like wild yeah
and like also like Connor as an
honorable fighter he knows he lost the
fight so what would he look like if he
loses a fight and then presses charges
what would you look like if he loses and
presses charges after all the people
that he's sort of exactly [ __ ] calling
the kettle black I think what will
happen and to kind of just close my
argument here what will happen is the
Nevada State Athletic Commission whose
sanctions that fight in Vegas will hand
down the the punishment that they decide
on for khabib and his team whether it's
stripping was already withheld yes what
his purse his payment basically for the
fight has been withheld so they'll
determine the punishment I don't know
what it'll be we're revoking visas for
future fights taking the belt away
finding him can they reckon do all they
can do all that they can do all of it
they can prevent him from ever fighting
in the US or the Nevada State state of
Nevada again which if you're banned from
fighting in Nevada like good luck in the
UFC so they'll do whatever they're gonna
do then after that the UFC and who knows
what goes on for that decision and who's
involved I don't know but after that
happens the UFC is going to take that
they're gonna follow that and kind of
you know follow suit with it so if they
if they say okay khabib can't fight for
nine months or two years or 12 months
because of what he did Dana's gonna be
like sorry you don't get the title we're
not gonna leave the title just the
vacant because he did this you win you
win this championship bout you won the
title but then it was stripped
afterwards that's you know I mean I
think we just gotta wait I think he's
got away with till the death letter
Commission speaks up I don't know I do
think it was exciting I think it was I
think he got it went too far and it
sucked but at the same time it wasn't
you know could have Mel hours so
all right last question for you is in
terms well we were talking to mark last
night about Joe Frazier and Muhammad Ali
yeah yeah and about how Muhammad Ali
would bring a small gorilla with him and
pretend it was Joe Frazier and call him
a gorilla in 60s and 70s do you think
when promoting a fight
that there should be things that are off
limits that don't serve to promote a
fight like religion politics race that
kind of thing I do like if you if you
were holding a press conference in your
Dana White and you heard Conor McGregor
or anybody basically just say like a
racial slur or well not even have the
press comment on Twitter or any number
something about religion yeah do you
think that that should be tolerated in
terms of promoting a fight I think the
only I don't think it should be I think
there definitely should be a no no list
to prevent things like this happening
also this should be used as an example
like hey everyone's not like you okay
you grew up in the United States you may
have a certain way of shaking things off
and doing it to promote a fight but dude
this guy's not like you he's from a
different part of the world he's from
Ireland I'm just talking about the
average UFC fighter like the precedents
it's setting from last night like I
think people just need to realize first
of all that not everyone's like you not
everyone takes things lightly and moves
on like some people just don't do that
they're from a different place in the
world and they just they're different I
think if I'm Dana White I think I take
this opportunity to to put like a hammer
down no religious no no sexual
orientation no you know no comments like
that just to just to try to do your best
to prevent this but at the same time if
someone does say that and they get fined
for it they're gonna eat that fine and
get to the fight and whatever might
happen might happens though you know
what I mean so like there's only so much
you can really do but I do think that
there should be like sort of a code of
conduct a code of conduct for for
pushing fights and promoting fights and
building rivalries feels like the
best-case scenario is that both sides
both parties are on board with
anything-goes we're just promoting a
fight and then at the end of the day
they both collect their paychecks and
shake hands and move on but like that's
just not
the case that's just not real life I'm
just asking in theory do you think it's
the responsibility of the organization
to have some sort of guidelines yeah I
do I do I just don't know how effective
it could be but it's better than nothing
mmhmm yeah I think yeah I think UFC
needs to step in and take take a make
this into something that wasn't for
nothing yeah you know but which could
happen yeah okay last question sorry do
you think that Connor deserves a rematch
with khabib because he was finished and
if not who would you like to see could
be fight next deserves it's like what
does that even mean now I do you think
that no idea or do you think that it
will happen because of now the chaos
that has ensued that would result in
millions of dollars in pay-per-view
money I think there will be a rematch
yes I don't think you know on paper he
would traditionally deserve a rematch
given the fight but he's Connor
and he makes the the organization more
money than they've ever made by far
mm-hmm every single time he shows his
face so maybe it's not right away maybe
they give Ferguson a shot maybe they put
Ferguson with Connor maybe they put pet
is with Connor may be Connor moves up or
down who knows they're gonna figure out
a way to keep Connor in the mix and I do
think eventually a rematch will happen
yeah I mean I was exciting to see Connor
fight I missed watching him fight hmm
anyway if you made it this far
welcome to the jenna julie podcast inc
so I was looking for podcast ideas and I
stumbled upon rhett and Link and their
ear biscuits podcast and I was scrolling
through their episodes and I found one
where they basically gave pretty goofy
you know like light-hearted advice to
people who have sent in issues that they
have at their workplace and so I thought
that could be fun to do in a very like
light way like we're pretty much it's
gonna meme it up here there might be a
couple pieces of actual advice you know
spliced in here for you to take home and
do what you want with but for the most
part we I basically tweeted out from
Jenna and Julian what are some of
you know the work for the workplace
issues that you deal with and would like
advice on so here we are
Jenna Julian are we our workplace
professionals because we work in our own
home we know all about the workplace and
we're going to give you some advice on
some of your problems oh boy so here
here here we go right sure okay and I'm
gonna keep it to first names only we'll
keep it to first names only so we don't
get you in trouble
Heather says I always have to take the
trash out but I'm little and it's so
hard for me to get the trash bags in the
big trashcan that the trash people come
and empty I always end up having to
swing the bags to build up momentum and
then fling them how do I make it easier
that sounds like fun
swinging the bags I would turn it into a
sport I would turn it into a sport have
you ever seen what's that Olympic event
where they spin around and then they let
it go I would do that except I would
invite some of your co-workers down and
I would put money on it and then slowly
as the money pop builds up of their
their money you know you're having them
participate then you slowly just like
back your way out of it and then before
you know it they're just competing throw
trash in the bin and you're not even in
the mix anymore you bring I know my
solution for that is you got to build
yourself a catapult you got to get a
plank and put all the trash on one side
with your back facing the dumpster jump
on the plank as hard as you can and long
to the trash into it so it goes over you
or you what if it rains down trash juice
and you're like and then slow motion
it's just like dripping trash juice in
your face it didn't it didn't hurt your
arms okay so no catapult
okay so pulley system get a rope like a
bear trap swing it up there and then
just like snip your rope or some [ __ ] I
don't know figure out a mechanic to let
go of the trash or you could go to this
in your Loudoun steam route and you you
oil up a path you get like literal like
like like what do you call like um
industrial oil and just
oil the the floor next to the trash and
get a cart and put the trash on it and
make a little ramp at the end of the oil
and just you're just gonna run as fast
as you can and just shove it into the
ramp and then the dolly will magically
stop in the trash will just fly into the
trash but how about just like a
stepstool that's pouring I personally do
you should go with option number one you
start a trash throwing contest and
there's money involved okay
you get people going you get people
excited you created a Facebook group for
it and then all of a sudden by week
three they're down there gambling their
money away to put trash into a bin and
you're like relieves of your
responsibility I don't think that that's
legal
don't tell HR right okay so this person
whose name is Marisa so my boss doesn't
always tell me when I'm working until my
shift starts and then sometimes he barks
then everyone keeps asking where's Jenna
not sure how to solve this what our
unique situation never heard of a
situation like that but it sounds tough
and I'm sorry that you're going through
that what I recommend you know it sounds
like a mod from our twitch stream I
would recommend trying to decipher the
barks a little bit better so that you
could just be on the same page with your
boss who barks because maybe to the
average year it sounds like a bark but
to the trained caring co-worker and my
son let her cry for help the end or you
could just quit or what what the hell
kind of solution is that learn how to
speak bark that's a good solution okay
learn how to speak fork and then
everyone keeps asking where's Jenna I
don't know how I mean maybe just respond
to people saying who's Jenna and then
just create a conspiracy that you don't
know who Jenna is nobody knows who chin
is and then it's like the Baron seen the
the Mandela effect the Berenstein bears
thing where it's like Jenna's suddenly
not in the name of anything anymore hmm
that's dark quite the solution
good swallow I work at a pottery place
this is Sydney okay I work in a pottery
place and we need customers phone
numbers to call them with their pot when
their pottery is ready for pickup mm-hmm
but people keep leaving support hotlines
as their numbers please up here's what
the hell really like people don't want
their pottery picked up okay why don't
you just ask for their email or
something like that if they don't want
to get called or do they just not want
their pottery and generally they just
come in to paint it or do it and they
don't want to keep it I would you
couldn't give them like an anonymous
slip of paper like hey listen I know you
came here with your girlfriend because
she [ __ ] begged you to come but if
you don't want to keep this piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] teacup that you just
painted for three hours you just let me
know on this piece of paper by writing
down a support hotline number and I
won't [ __ ] call you and I'm gonna
throw this thing story in the trash it's
like a Pottery safe word I like that but
that's like a lot of words he just said
so how are you gonna communicate all
that I know it's in the air drop it to
them yeah okay drops is a solution to a
lot of things or it's it's a note in the
bathroom that's like hidden because the
only time you would just like really go
to the bathroom while you're doing
pottery with your hands all covered in
clay is if you're having a miserable
[ __ ] time and you do you have no
intention of keeping whatever you're
gonna go wash your hands and take a
break from the misery that your yes and
you see a little note that's like hey if
you don't want to keep your teacup just
write down this number and and I won't
call you here's what I would do but
that's a good one
I would take one of the defective
pottery pieces that you're not going to
use no one's gonna buy you take it out
to the back and you record a video of
yourself stomping it in two bits while
you yell curse words at it and you keep
that video and anyone who sends you that
or leaves there at that fake phone
number you email that video to them and
say this is what happened to your
pottery piece and then they never come
back and you already got their money in
well okay yeah also since you already
have their money you could take up your
own sport look just like the trash sport
but like just take all the pottery that
OH
left me a hotline number great you add
it to your collection and then you just
go out on the weekends and you just
throw them wherever the [ __ ] you want
for fun hmm
with your friends that's good it's clay
right if it's pottery it's clay so if
you smash it in the ground it's gonna
decompose not like you're littering is
this literally literally littering I
guess everything decomposes my idea is
flawed here hmm smash it and then sweep
it up and throw it and keep the video of
you smashing it just for like blackmail
purposes yeah right because you want to
have power over these people who have
come in terrorize your workplace hmm so
just keep that one on hand you could add
different filters to it to send to
different people you know so doesn't
look the same and then write a ransom
note okay okay fair enough
Brooklyn says guys peeing on the floor
in the shared bathroom hmm here's how I
would put up a sign in the met in the
shared bathroom and I would it would say
smile you're on camera and parenthesis
stop peeing on the floor even though
there's no camera but then they're gonna
think there's a camera and then on the
inside of every single stall and on top
the the pee stalls you put another sign
that says why did you ignore the first
sign or watching you winky face I don't
think I have a better solution than that
honestly just a sign that says smile
you're on camera is completely tariffs
yeah or or you put it I'd also be like
well this is illegal or you do your best
detective work I don't know what this
means but try to figure out who's doing
it and then send them a memo with C
seeing everybody and say hey I know Izzy
who peed on the floor could you stop
smiley face how do you know these people
are peeing on the floor is it like on
the shower floor early no it's a shared
bathroom so I'm sure it's like the guy's
just missing the toy yeah yeah yeah
that's a thing you go to any dirty
public bathroom there's pee on the floor
yeah or you secretly go to the janitor
and pay him overtime you say hey I want
you to stay I want you to stay in the
bathroom all day today okay
I'll pay you I'm contracting you to do
this and he's the detective no one's
gonna look twice at the janitor in the
bathroom but he's secretly got his eye
on you so if he sees someone pee on the
floor one ounce of Pete drops on the
floor he's there for it he's gonna
remember those shoes so then he's gonna
go around the office and look at all
their shoes and by process of
elimination
he goes up to the guy where he found the
shoes and he pees on his shoes so you're
saying that he's retaliating on us for
an I baby
perhaps and perhaps an accident by
urinating on them hi for and on I can't
think of a better way to get back at him
okay and then when the janitor gets
fired you say boy sorry we really
shouldn't have done that and then you
put it on him you say I don't know what
you were thinking don't do anything
literally don't do anything that way say
my boss has 6 to 7 espresso shots every
morning and therefore has crazy eyes and
runs around the restaurant the entire
ship how do I calm him oh my god
easy switch it out with decaf before he
gets there no oh that's cruel because
some people are like addicted to
caffeine yeah this guy needs to he's got
crazy eyes that's conducive work
environment what about every time you
look to you with crazy eyes instead of
listening to whatever he says you just
break out and singing some Enya see if
that will comment what's that oh that's
good that's good I also think just
switching it out of decaf would pretty
much overall solve this whole problem
but maybe figure out something that he
likes maybe you like small animals and
you bring them in Iceland what is define
crazy I don't know what that like he's
just looking at ya be nice just but like
what is that like I have caffeine eyes
every day because I drink caffeine and I
have eyes so like you know what gives
find a way to melt him to his heart
because no matter how caffeinated you
are if you're like melted you still melt
bring him a stuffed animal I'm gonna
take care of it
bring me one stuffed animal bring him a
bring her stuffed animal a Game Boy say
hey oh yeah bring him a Game Boy relax
and sit outside then wise outside just
just smash the coffee machine it's a bit
no no that's good that's good right mmm
Mac asks every time I go to the water
cooler Karen is just once up ahead of me
and I feel like I can't dominate my
conversations that work what do I do
good question Mac you sign up for the
skim newsletter and right now you could
do it for completely free no charge at
all you just go to this skim Comus th es
ki mmm - MS are common and Julianne sign
up and then magically every morning
you're gonna have the skin newsletter
with all the information about what's
happening in the world
easy ready to read conveniently at the
top of your inbox every morning so you
can show up and say hey Karen I found
out what the [ __ ] you're doing and and
also reach out to the skin customer
service and try to unsubscribe Karen so
you got that leg up but regardless
you're gonna be filled in with the skin
and when you sign up with the skin calm
slash Jenna Jillian you're entered to
win a $250 Visa gift card which if you
won you could just buy your own couple
water cooler so you don't have to deal
with Karen at all as Karen is just a
pain and she doesn't even work she just
stands in the water cool all day the
skin is really making it easier to live
smarter every day all the top news
stories the things that you really need
to know curated for you and your email
inbox every morning completely for free
everything that's going on guys like the
things that you really don't want to
miss whether they're good they're bad
you need to be in the note you don't
want to be at the Dallas Cowboys
cheerleader camp and not know what the
me - movement is you don't want to be
anywhere and not know what that is but
you keeps you in the know and it'll make
you the most educated person including
Karen in your workplace go to the th es
ki mmm calm sighs Jenna Julian and sign
up right now it's completely free
literally just free okay also guys me
and ease you already know how much I
love me Inez I'm wearing them right now
I wear them all day every single game
but did you know they have the most
comfortable lounge pants and T's as well
Mandy's lounge pants are made of the
micro modal fabric which is three times
hotter than cotton just like their
underwear when you join the membership
you can get all this stuff the lounge
pants T's undies everything they make
including the socks which I love too but
you get it for less than everybody else
because you remember okay Mandy's
underwear the softest things you'll wear
in fun prints that you can match with
socks or even a bralette I haven't worn
one of those but they look very
comfortable with their hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee for some reason
if for some reason you don't love the
whatever piece you buy from a knees they
will return it you can return for a
hundred percent of your money so you
don't lose out on anything
also guys you get 15% off your first
pair right now literally right now and
free shipping by going to meet on these
that's meu n di es comm slash Jenna
Julie check it out and then if you're
looking for some clothes maybe some
jeans some jacket some hats some shoes
that me Andy's couldn't get for you go
to thread up what is thread up well they
have all the best brands that you might
like adidas Free People Gap Lululemon
guess guess what therapy thread up is an
amazing service that you can buy
secondhand clothing in good condition
for up to 90% off
estimated retail price you're gonna
thread up that's thr edu P comm slash
Jenna Julian and you will get an extra
30% off so you're getting 90% off retail
price and then another 30% off because
you listen to us and you're smart and we
love you it's the perfect place when
you're looking to update your wardrobe
on a budget there are so many awesome
options as well as crazy deals going on
at any given time every item is in
excellent condition and some even still
have the tags on them you'd be surprised
at the selection you can find at this
place if you love to shop you need to
check out these deals right now on
thredUP guys check it out go to thread
up
thre DUP comm swatch annejulien extra
30% off on top of the 90% off I'm no
mathematician that sounds like 120
percent off that doesn't mean you're
gonna get paid to buy these clothes but
it's a lot off okay a lot off thank you
for that question
wonderful question someone named Jake
hmm asked when people run in the pool
deck and don't listen and then they trip
and hit their head how do I stop this
also can I have $900 I need it for a
thing you cannot have $900 for a thing
so I'm just ringing your lifeguard here
yeah this this makes me think that
you're a lifeguard what I think you
should do they're banned from the pool
space if they don't get to run and then
get to swim sorry yeah sorry I'm up on
my feet up here because Marvel's sitting
on my lap cuz he doesn't feel good today
okay here's the solution welcome to my
feet look no further fam you been from
the pool get on the pole they're great
they're gonna put on a wig and come back
in a different disguise you know how
these these people work okay here's what
you got to do before work one day head
over to Home Depot with the company
credit card.not yeah okay grab a bucket
of the most cherry red paint you could
find okay get to the pool early spill
the paint splatter it make it look like
it was a big bloody accident and just
put a little sign there you know the
sign that sits like a little thing that
says wet floor except repaint that sign
and says a guy died here because he ran
on the pool deck don't do it you know my
god too much I think it would be
effective if I was going to the public
pool that day and I had my floaties and
I was ready to go and I was ready to
jump I was ready to run along the side
of the pool in the life guy was looking
and I saw a big blood spill that had
been so messy that it's stained into
cherry red paint that smells like paint
I would not run hmm yeah you know wrong
or you could also get like a fire hose
and bring it up to your lifeguard
station so when someone starts running
you spray them with it so hard that they
fall over anyways
but then you're assaulting them via
water hose mm-hmm no because you're a
lifeguard and whatever you say goes oh
the law doesn't play lifeguards I know I
read that one time in lifeguards digest
yeah and then you scream at them it's my
job to keep you safe and then you jump
off of the
the 16-foot lifeguard tower you just
keep spraying them just get him good you
know mm-hmm I think that would
definitely show them between Julian's
solution and - I think we have an on
problem on our hands
yeah sometimes Zoe uh sometimes
participants at the gym I work at take
our walkie-talkies and keep them while
they work out a little confused by this
what walk it first of all wait wait wait
read it over again participants at the
gym I work at take our walkie-talkies
and keep them while they work out they
keep them with them while they work out
so they like my question is what
walkie-talkie don't work there look at
they work there's no participants yeah
what does that mean like patrons people
who pay for a membership and go work out
I'm assuming this is just like we're up
to them and go give me that [ __ ]
walkie-talkie no there's a much better
way to do this can you call the weirdest
sex hotline you could find turn on
speaker Julie the other walkie-talkie
next to it and so wherever they are
they're gonna get completely embarrassed
right it's a flawless solution thank you
thank you and then I'll never take it
again unless they want unless they liked
it that's then you have a big different
problem hmm my cubicle buddy farts loud
and often I've tried embarrassing him by
asking him loudly and in front of people
to cut it out but it's not slowing down
anytime soon that comes from Alison you
could just get a gas mask you were
through that or you could buy a fart
sound effect machine and every time he
farts you fart louder yeah yes no here's
what you do what you Chum up the office
manager who has who has a connection to
the intercom feature and you hook up a
fart machine so your desk so you have
the bun in your desk but every time you
press it a fart plays over the whole
office so anytime he farts he's just
fart for the office mm-hmm so it's until
everything's out of control then you're
just living in a fart box and then
somebody's got to do something but you
know what it's not you and now the
problems bigger than you and out of your
hands
so you've basically not solved the
problem but you've made it so it's not
your personal problem anymore or do this
every time they far than actually you
just saying this person farted right
really well that's what he said he did
he tried to embarrass me no but like
just like screaming this guy's just
[ __ ] farted smell everybody he farted
could you just like eat something that
makes you fart a lot and then just try
to do it back to him that's a good
that's a good idea
but I don't know how closely you're in
touch with your diet and your your body
to know exactly what makes you fart or
you just get a stink bomb and just
destroy it all like that fart spray or
something that smells like fart every
time he farts you just like do one hot
mist in the air but you wear a gas mask
oh oh I don't get your job done here's
what you're not getting fired
here's your day what you put a megaphone
under his chair well essentially the
same thing because you're just
amplifying a fart noise one's real one's
fake or you could just put a whoopee
cushion under your chair and fart spray
so every time he farts you fake fart by
sitting on the whoopee cushion and
spraying fart spray mm-hmm so you just
you've engaged in a fart war no and
someone's gonna come out on top and it's
gonna be you hey you know what that's
good you didn't start the fart war
yes I like you Thank You Chelsea ass
having people giggle as I say the
infamous line hi welcome to Chili's so
I'm guessing your green Chili's or Adam
really ruined your life huh I think you
got a dresser I'll pass them every day
or or I know I know a very easy solution
hmm you have the vine playing on a loop
like on the little podium when you walk
in so that you go like this you go and
you press play it and it does it for you
then like you just carry an iPad and
play that you mount it to the podium or
you strap it to your chain so you have a
chain with an iPad
and you up to people and you just press
play and it says hi welcome to Chili's
or you could walk up to the table say hi
welcome to Chili's like start blowing
your vape smoke out on the table and
have like ask one of them to blow it out
and then looking at me go Adam and then
now that everyone's laughing you can
take their order yeah so you start with
the vine joke even though it's your job
to say hi welcome to Chili's but then
you continuously like bombard them with
more vines yeah or you could tell your
boss that you're now becoming a
professional Shakespeare impersonator
actor you just start dressing like
you're from another century and go hello
dost thou feel welcomed in Chili's so
you say in this Shakespearean something
like that just just you could or open
bienvenidos a Chili's pretend to you
speak Spanish
you mean just speak Spanish do it this
person named Jason said I play games
with my coworker and he always takes my
loop he also always throws these stun
grenades at me after he locks me in a
shed honestly I'm not sure if I should
be upset what do you think that sounds
like a horrible situation that sounds
like Jason Sully and it sounds like he's
talking about playing with you I would
quit
I would I would find new teammates
because it doesn't sound like that guy's
gonna ever stop because it's probably
way too funny you're a bully it's way
too funny what you just described as
hilarious I'm not helping you with your
problem Oh Lauren says I have a similar
coworker
he also takes my loo and pretends to
drop items for me while driving I think
this is microaggressions but HR won't
listen what should I do
Lauren yeah I gathered that much oh
they're talking about playing pub G I'm
sorry are you over the joke is that
what's happening my bad I'm a lecturer
in class B says I'm a lecturer in class
so having students on their phones is a
problem here's what you do
you go drop them all you get you prepare
a picture that you're gonna just airdrop
relentlessly to everybody okay and then
you just airdrop it the end and the
airdrop message says I see you on your
phone look up right now you're getting
enough just threaten your students
forget the airdrop just bring a weapon
and oh my god I just melt like an axe or
something just carry it over your
shoulder just walk her out like paste a
message that says hey looking look up at
the front of class just flip the axe up
on your shoulder mm-hmm dress as a
dressed as a lumberjack grow beard or
put a fake one on and just like oh dude
the thing with that serial killers do
and just like scratch it against the
wall so it makes this really loud noise
yeah eat your lesson while you do that
or you can just you know airdrop them
pictures of like Nic Cage over and over
and over again but what if they turn
their air drop off is there a way to
like override someone's air drop and
just force all the air drops on because
if there are you should hack their phone
so there are drops all the ways on and
then just drop them viruses onto their
phone mm-hmm I feel like my my actual
answer to that is like that sucks and
that's that makes your job frustrating
but also a it could be a person's
learning style that's having something
tactile actually helps them learn better
even though they could possibly be very
distracted but also like why do you give
a [ __ ] like if they're gonna fail the
class depending how old they are well
they're in high school then yeah yeah
but I call it sounds like a college
lecturer because she said lecturer my
thing is like I get why you would beep
it like I get that their destinies in
their hands if they're not gonna pay
attention take notes they're gonna fail
whatever but at the same time if you
care about what you're lecturing like it
is annoying to have people just on their
phone sucks so I would honestly the most
embarrassed I've ever been in a class at
any sort is like I've been caught on my
phone and then the all the I'll get made
an example of like my teacher or
professor will like stop everything till
it's like dead quiet and then I all of a
sudden realize that everyone's looking
at me and then I literally never did
so I would do that but I would up at one
to where I would the moment you see
someone on their phone you hold up a
sign to everyone who's actually looking
at you say hey everyone else get on your
phones and look at them right now and
then the professor you get on your phone
and look at it and then everyone's just
wait I will say so when I was in college
I didn't have a laptop and many many
many students did not have laptops like
I had a desktop computer and so every
time I would go to class that would have
my notes so there is no like looking at
my phone there's no looking at my laptop
but I feel like nowadays it's very
common for people to take notes on a
laptop or an iPad or something like that
so like what's the difference to you if
someone's looking at their phone or
their laptop chances are they're both
just [ __ ] looking at something that
has nothing to do with the glass so if
you envision that their phone is really
just their laptop they're just [ __ ]
around to you know because yeah they're
taking notes in the laptop or they're
not at all or they're doing both but
it's there it's their funeral so yeah
when I was in school I I didn't have
that so I just sat there terribly alert
and listening nice it all went into my
brain all of it Holly says not knowing
how to gently explain to my coworker
that the sleep lotion from bed from Bath
& Body Works doesn't actually make you
go to sleep like she doesn't get that
it's not medicated and it's concern
whenever I use it I just like lavender
here's what you do you make sure she's
looking one-day take some sleep lotion
and then just pass out pretend like fall
like directly on the floor I just
pretend like you're asleep and then wake
up like two hours later like oh my god
that was such a good night yeah it
requires you to performance act yeah you
have to performance act like you're
asleep you know
that'll do it and then that I've
actually made perpetuator worse because
then she's gonna want to keep you away
from it more
just change the label put a new label on
top of the sleep lotion and sit and just
write awake lotion mm-hmm and then take
it and then all you got to do is be
really energetic mm-hmm I think that's a
good one yeah good stuff by the way
don't do anything we told you any of you
this is horrible advice hmm I think this
is a good one that none 95% of my
coworkers are religious and I feel like
I have to tread lightly cup Len SIA
cosplay is Jesus Christ and going to
work like that that is the worst cosplay
is Jesus Christ vice I have just like
Michael did in the office just cosplay
as Jesus he did that in the office yeah
he he dressed up as Santa
but then Phyllis was Santa so he got
really upset so he turned the Santa
outfit inside out and turn turn into
jesus outfit basically and he took the
mustache ah it was just a white beard
and he was in his words he was hurt
petulant Jesus Peter petulant Jesus what
were the results of him dressing as
Jesus in a workplace I honestly could
really ever got that far with HR I think
they kind of just dropped it well we're
his co-workers reactions very very upset
yeah it was very negative so how is this
a solution well it's a solution for you
let's yeah not them right you're looking
for a solution solution you mm-hmm
just cosplay as Jesus when in doubt what
if what if they're not Catholic or
Christian or anything
Jesus what if they're all Jewish
cosplays Jesus you think that would go
over well I don't think there's anything
remotely bad that could happen from
cosplaying as Jesus and are overly
sensitive really just working and then
just walk around see what would I do
[Laughter]
everyone's gonna be pissed this is how
to get fired in under an hour with Jenna
and Julian oh my god oh boy what
priceless advice that was hmm well for
those of you who are expecting like more
serious advice a I'm sorry but
I'm also like not sorry because if we
gave you that advice it might have been
bad and who knows you might have like
taken in gone fired and then blamed us I
don't know I would have sucked I know
there were a lot of people asking like
advice like you know I'm young for my
position a lot of my peers are older
than me and they talk down to me and
stuff like that like a lot of that
shit's just tough man and people are
like really shitty when it comes to the
workplace because they feel entitled
based on age or whatever it might be and
I think that like you know just as
cheesy as it sounds just really just
kind of staying focused and you know
keeping your head down and doing your
work and not really minding the people
around you it's very difficult to do but
yeah it's like probably some of my best
advice and also like there's some advice
of like you know mm I show up early and
I get work done whereas my co-workers
show up directly on time and don't do
anything extra I would just say like you
know you little selfish
you know do your job and take care your
responsibilities in a good way that you
think your superior would like but at
the same time if you see that you're
doing something that is really just kind
of like aggravating you because no one
else is participating in it and just
like self-preservation you know yeah
don't kill yourself to to do extra work
when it's just not really cared about I
mean I was always that person that was
doing some extra work depending on the
job you know and it is definitely
aggravating it unfair when you think
about how unbalanced that is or like how
you care so much about your job and it
seems like the other people around you
get away with the bare minimum and don't
care and that's really frustrating but
like if anything what you get to take
with you for the rest of your life is
your work ethic you know that's true
like you may not being currently
rewarded for the way that you're
behaving at your job but in the future
you will and the future that it will get
you farther than the people that show up
and do nothing in care and don't care
you know what I mean
so don't let that discourage you enough
to where you change your work ethic but
also finding a happy medium that keeps
you sane is also important like if
you're breaking your back to do
something without anyone rewarding you
for that or caring that you do it like
you think about the workhorses that you
know of our friends and us and people
where it's like you can work at the same
job for 10 years so where you are the
workhorse
and people just genuinely start to take
advantage of you you're not getting paid
your fair amount like you're just you're
doing everything all the time and like
no one has your back there's no
promotion there's you know what I mean
ten [ __ ] years like you know you need
to stand up for yourself need to look
out for your sanity but don't let the
actions and attitude of others even if
that's your boss influence your future
work ethic or current work ethic but do
take care of yourself and keep your
sanity great advice all of it crazy
advice and I think there's like there is
a point of realizing that you're it's
time to move on because you've given so
much to a company or you do work so well
but you feel like nobody is appreciating
it and you're getting false promises you
have more to offer than what you're
being exactly no you're like I started
here when I was 20 years old and I'm 30
now and I don't want to do busy work
anymore yeah you know and with that said
like if you haven't reached that
absolute point yet
like realize that like there are
benefits even if they're not readily
apparent there are benefits to you know
doing the the extra work and going the
extra mile and actually showing people
that you care because what might even
happen you know regardless of if you get
a promotion or whatever you might just
come across someone who's like you you
know what I mean by doing that work or
showing interest in work that that you
may not yet have responsibility for you
never know who what kind of person
you're gonna meet who might appreciate
that in you and maybe you'll get a
friendship out of it mm-hmm
you know but it sounds like you guys
have a pretty solid handle on your work
places and if you don't well now you do
now you definitely don't don't I see
yellow you know bill didn't trash
catapults and [ __ ] to start a betting
ring around the trash dumpster and
you're just gonna make money and it's
just just get arrested it's gonna be
fine don't even worry about it thank you
guys for listening the podcast we
appreciate you sending your questions
and I hope you enjoyed listening to us
gave you bad advice about your
workplaces yeah
well see you guys next week on gender
doing podcast have a wonderful week
[Music]
[Music]